Peter Lee the author of comrade J and
Sergey Tretyakov the subject of comrade
J welcome to both of you thank you very
much for being my guest this morning our
pleasure
I would like to start with you people
this is an extraordinary story it is a
story that is it is the most up-to-date
story we have had of a an intelligence
officer of Sergei treachery coughs rank
choosing to defect to the United States
and he tells an incredible story and as
I read the book which is quite
fascinating one of the first things that
happened when you were approached about
doing this story which you said no you
were not interested so I think would be
interesting for us to know how did you
become interested well I became
interested when I actually met Sergei I
receive I had done books about the John
Walker spy case and about Aldrich Ames
the CIA traitor and periodically I got
calls from people from the KGB saying oh
I want to tell you my life story and
most of them weren't very interesting
and so I said no I'm not interested I'm
not interested and then a friend of mine
from the FBI called and he said you need
to meet this person he didn't give me a
name
and so I said okay and then it was very
dramatic I they told me arrive at this
place at this time and when I got there
two FBI agents were there they took me
up to a suite where there are two CIA
agents and in walks Sergey and they I
knew instantly that he was somebody
important because I actually remembered
his name from when he defected and he
was a mystery he defected in 2000 and
disappeared off the grid and I knew he
was the highest-ranking Russian
intelligence officer to defect and of
course then as I spoke to him the story
got better and better
well you tell a fascinating story let's
turn to Sergey Tretyakov you took an
extraordinary step with your life you
took an extraordinary risk with your
life we're very fortunate to be with us
today
we're very glad to have you let me go
back to rather than go all the way back
in your life which I would like to do to
an extent I would just like to ask you
have now lived in the United States
since you came actually to Manhattan to
be the number two ahead of what would be
the equivalent of the CIA station the
rezidentura
you chose to defect in 2000 you've now
lived here since that time so in almost
10 years 8 years 8 years mm I escaped in
October 2000 yes October 2000 and you
have also since then become an American
citizen
two years ago we became American
citizens I mean my wife my daughter and
myself and were very proud and it was
one of the happiest days in our lives
the story of comrade J which would have
been your name inside the inside the KGB
was comrade Jean as I john-john French
yes and you would have been a and you
depict yourself as an extraordinary
loyal very effective KGB later SVR SVR
officer that was the successor
organization and yet the story that you
tell is one of great great
disillusionment can you just you know in
a few words give us a sense of the
nature of that disillusionment because
you had everything going for him you
were a success story you had come in you
had been trained you had survived the
sort of vicious and fighting that can
take place in the KGB later SVR and you
were on the you were on the cusp of
becoming a general and being in general
and the KGB is equivalent to having
arrived it is it is the sea it is the
top position and yet you became
disillusioned what was behind that
disillusionment first of all I was Ray
as a patriot and when I chose to work
for the KGB for the Russian intelligence
it was it was the matter of money
it was the matter I wanted to serve my
country in the most effective way and I
thought that intelligence is one of the
of the best opportunities I had a
skyrocketing career for three years in
in the beginning of my career I was the
head of the young Communist League of
the intelligence I was captain at the
time but my status was awful lifted in
general I was always successful and
people like me usually don't defect I
never had any financial issues problems
I was successful officer definitely if I
returned back to Russia I would be
general or even something more that
means that general or with very high
position I was offered many positions
like this and then I defected probably
for my former colleagues it's the main
question they're asking what drove this
guy to the to that decision when I was
the head of for example young Communist
League comes from all of the
intelligence a lot of dramatic events
took place in the intelligence people
who were betrayed by Ames than Hansen
were arrested and executed and I
attended some trials on Vronsky Street
it's where they were trial believe me
even for someone with good nervous
system it's quite an experience to
attend these trials they were all
organized to scare us to show what will
happen to you
if you defect or if you do something
wrong it means in my particular case I
knew what exactly awaits me in case of
failure because all these people who
were executed they never had the never
was even close to my position in the
intelligence but again it was a dramatic
decision we became disillusioned we I
mean the whole family first told my wife
and myself because daughter my daughter
was too young just to think about things
like this at that time and to make this
story short I decided we decided to do
something
finally to do something useful in our
lives and not to serve the people who
call themselves a Russian government and
who perform in my opinion the genocide
of Russian people of people who live in
in in Russia and I had a choice to
become part of this genocidal team or to
do something else you know you you
describe going to the trials of KGB
officers who were tried and executed I'm
thinking there's one incident in your
book within a few pages where there were
in fact trials and executions of three
officers bigger soft Motorin and poor
Yakov and you were then I think about 29
years old roughly yes and you described
going to a kg a dinner of other KGB
officers where the executions were a
noun when they excursions were announced
and everyone stood and applauded yes and
I was among those who applauded but I'm
but I but I said but in the book it's
quite clear that that and you say in one
in one passage that you realize that you
were in an organization where to succeed
you had to be a wolf and so you would
have just a sharper teeth than anyone
else
but having joined the the having been in
the Young Pioneers have having been
quite patriotic you you were a true
believer we use that phrase at reliever
what was it like then as you moved up
the ranks and you were exposed to this
incredibly intimidating situation
execution everybody applauds and then
you also and this comes out so clearly
in the book the very vicious infighting
inside the KGB where people would stab
one another in the back and and yet you
still there were certain people you
trusted but others that I mean it was
there were so many people you could not
trust I mean it was like a an incredibly
almost gangster like situation yes some
extent yes
the life in KGB the whole logic of KGB
it's quite difficult to understand for
Westerners for Americans that
organization was very cruel towards the
the population but believe me this
organization was even much more cruel
towards towards their own
representatives like these executions
and I remember Khrushchev who desist not
long ago he was the head at that time of
the first chief Directorate of KGB
intelligence he was very proud to
announce like traitor Mattern executed
and we're all standing and applauding I
I I'm rethinking this situation you know
and I was asking myself what I thought
at that time when I was applauding to a
new maturity he was a very nice guy and
I felt pity for him he is a human guy
being he's a nice person but I thought
yes it's the way to go he betrayed the
organization he betrayed the country and
you must understand how dramatic it was
to me to my family to go to become what
we became yes
and I always underlined that I never did
it for money I was never approached I
had a very bad reputation
I was never seduced I was never bought
it was our decision and I don't regret
even for one minute that we started
doing what we what we did let me just
ask you Peter Lee when you met Sergei
and and then you began sat down to do
your interviews and you described
something like a hundred and twenty six
hours of taped interviews that you plus
just your normal conversation did you
have the sense of a man with a great
weight on him that was being lifted
what was your sense of Sergei the man I
was you know I had done interviews with
John Walker the spy the naval officer
who betrayed our country I've done
interviews with Aldrich Ames who of
course was responsible for CIA deaths
and of course I went into this trying to
think how is he different how is he
going to be different and I remember
when I was in Moscow and interviewed
general Boris Kalimantan who was perhaps
one of the greatest KGB cold warriors
who really attacked the United States
and he said there is no romance with
Americans it's always the money and that
was the first thing that I saw was so
different about Sergei he wasn't
interested in doing this for the money
he had changed his whole attitude and he
had as he describes an allergy towards
the new Russians who had come into power
he saw the corruption he
so the greedy tells the story about one
officer who worked for him who was a
lousy officer who he wanted to get rid
of but he was just stealing so much
money for the people back in Moscow they
were giving him awards this betrayed
everything but I think one of the most
telling things about Sergei is he not
only helped us he joined us he's a US
citizen
you never saw Walker you never saw Ames
you never saw these kind of people
saying I want to live in Russia you know
I want your money but here it was not
money and I think that is a key
motivation and understanding him you
know there are many times when we'd have
conversations where I'd say Sergei trust
me the United States is it's not as
great as you think it is and he'd say oh
no no no trust me it is better than you
know it is having grown up here you're
spoiled you don't understand what it's
really like to live like I lived so this
this man not only says he's put his life
on the line but he believes us and that
was a distinct difference and when
people say oh you know Walker Ames
Sergei they're they're not from the same
mold why don't we stay with that that
subject you've now been here as a
citizen you now are a citizen taking the
pledge become an American citizen you
and your wife you are now a daughter and
your daughter and you now have had an
opportunity to see America as they say
warts and all and you see the things
that Pete and I could now sit down and
complain about you know whether it's
that there's this election system that's
now run for two years and we still have
no idea I mean the British do it in six
weeks takes us two years but the other
things the problems with our economy the
inequities in in our in our system in
our medical insurance you know one of
the great visions of socialism of course
was to have universal medical care and
that was that was part of the vision
that you bought into as a young as a
young Soviet later as a Russian and now
you see that we do have inequities that
is that is not
fair for everybody so you've had a
chance to get a perspective on your
original vision of America as a hope for
you and representing a better life do
you still feel that way
absolutely first of all there are no
ideal countries
I never idealized for example Russian
American foreign policy there are a lot
of things in the society like you
mentioned them which need to be improved
but my vision of Americans and America
Americans and America make mistakes but
then then they they correct them then
they move forward then again they make
mistakes but then they move forward
I always feel a progress again with the
understanding that I am NOT idealizing a
lot of things which I can see in this
country by but still I think United
States is the main promoter of democracy
and the leader of the world and for
example if we had admit that I worked
for four American government I would
never work for any other gun why because
this is the country which leads the
world and it's my Ummah is my belief
sometimes Pete he is more skeptical but
this is what we believe in the power
Hawk Peter one interesting thing though
is although and this is a man who was a
high-ranking Russian intelligence
officer and I say in the book that he
worked for the CIA and the FBI for our
country for many years taking over 5000
top-secret documents out he will still
tell you and he can correct me if he
will correct me if I'm wrong that he
believes Russian intelligence is better
I can't because I never worked in in
American intelligence but I assumed that
according to the to the information
known to the public Russian intelligence
was the most effective in the world one
of the reasons first of all Russian
intelligence was a rather cruel system
they were always pushing you to the edge
I remember in New York residency general
Toolik of came he was the head of the
intelligence we were all gathered in
this t-intersection in the residency and
he was talking about the what's going on
in the in the center just informing us
about the politics whatever but then he
says colleagues please remember if you
are successful successful in recruiting
you will have better apartment will
promote you will decorate you but if
it's a failure will crucify this is a
very key to be approached and then we
had a private conversation and I asked
him which is love and [ __ ] there is no
logic because if you risk your life for
the country the country must you must
have a wall behind you and he told me
Sergei you know you know the system the
same way as I I know it how it was but
in order to be successful in the Russian
intelligence you must achieve concrete
results conclude results recruitment and
Russian intelligence historically
traditionally relies upon mainly human
intelligence all these bars satellites
interception it's good it's effective
but it's exhilarating main have sources
human sources and this is the whole
logic of organization this school of
the organization they teach you how to
recruit they want you to recruit people
and sometimes when I analyze some cases
I said oh it's it's not possible no it's
possible when you start working you can
achieve amazing results before you start
work you think oh no no no it's it's
nonsense
we can't recruit someone like this and
then we start working and then you see
the result it's worked I know that among
the operations and operational
activities that you were in charge of in
when you were in Manhattan was what we
call covert action and and that was in
trying to promote both dissension and
unrest within the United States to the
extent you could and anti-americanism
abroad to help give America blocka one
of you could chat a bit about that it's
called MS in Russian measures of support
before it was called active measures
it was Department a in the in Russian
intelligence when Soviet Union ceased to
exist and people start thinking started
thinking that Cold War is over I know
that American side was asking Russians
guys please stop these active measures
they're very embarrassing Russians
agreed and they changed the title from
department a department ms same people
same mechanisms same approach nothing
changed and actually it's a very
effective mechanism and very cheap
mechanism to embarrass us to embarrass
other countries examples for example
like in Europe something something
simple if you have a source journalists
or some other source
horses who can publish something like
this for example mean Americans planted
nuclear devices on the territory of of
Germany in case of war if Russian tanks
start advancing to Europe they'll blow
this nuclear devices and then they
destroyed Russian military machine but
Germany will be Russian military machine
and when information like this goes to
to the circles of population which are
not that prepared to analyze things they
start thinking Oh Americans there be the
bad people said in the book there is
example of nuclear winter yes which was
very embarrassing for the for the United
States when Soviet Union ceased to exist
when KGB disappeared when SVR took over
all the functions of former KGB abroad
active methods became believe me it was
my job more aggressive and more numerous
than it was you to destroy it well I
don't know if we can quite attribute it
to the KGB SVR but there is a lot of
anti Americanism now around the world
some of which we brought on ourselves
but from what you say and what you say
America remains a top priority a top
target within the SVR both to foster
anti Americanism as well as to create
dissension within PQ what a comment well
one of the you are acting and asking
about active measures one of the things
Sergei talks about is how Moscow would
send instructions to New York and many
of his officers would be dispatched to
the New York Public Library to get onto
the computer so they'd hide their
identity to just put out reports and
statements that would be like 98 percent
factual but have a little twist in there
a lot of them about Chechnya trying to
turn public opinion and they'd flood the
internet with these that look legitimate
and it hopes that someone would pick up
you know some little nugget
you know Sergey talks about the end of
the Cold War and and and can you tell
about the target thing I mean people ask
me all the time what changed after the
Cold War was over
who told you that Cold War was ever in
Russian military doctrine Soviet
military doctrine there was an official
definition of a main enemy United States
NATO in China in today's and tells us
doctrine there is definition of main
targets United States NATO and China for
me the previous definition potential
main enemy is less aggressive its
potential but when you are my main
target you are my main target right now
not potentially it means even in theory
nothing changed you know on the level of
of doctrine you know the other thing is
as you know in Russian government there
are a lot of people with KGB background
including President Putin we all have
how they said brains made the same in
the same factory KGB factory yes and
traditionally we never trusted
information from the MFE mister of
Foreign Affairs not because it was
better for me but was open information
the information which you can get from
the newspaper we all trusted in
intelligence information which was more
more secret more accurate and that's why
demand for the intelligence information
in today's Russian government is
probably higher than it was during the
Soviet period because not so many KGB is
we're in real power at that time in
Russian I remember it was 2000 it was
August I think the advanced team came
before Putin's came to attend the
General Assembly and general more of the
head of the secret Russian FSO
equivalent of American Secret Service
was instructing Lavrov and he was by the
way he was already drunk at the time but
anyway he was telling him please I want
to remind you that mr. Putin relies upon
information from these guys support them
and make their life as easy as possible
actually I never had we never had any
problems with plumhoff
we existed very peacefully very
productively and I think that Lavrov was
never offended in his whole professional
career like that okay why don't we take
a break now and when we come back I'd
like to address the issue of what of a
person you considered one of the most
important reporting sources in the
United States afterwards and several
other c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts more with Pete
Earley
Sergey treta cough and Peter earnest in
a moment as executive producer of The
Washington journal I know that fewer
calls are an important part of our
on-air programming it's part of who we
are we're committed to opening up the
phone line so you can talk directly to
journalists elected officials and other
decision-makers we began taking calls
during the 1980 presidential campaign
which made us the first nationwide
daytime calling program on television
and ever since then we've been inviting
viewers to call in speak and be heard we
take calls each morning on the
Washington journal during our coverage
of Congress on the campaign trail after
important speeches and as a part of our
key event coverage our aim is to hear
from many different points of view from
across the political spectrum so if you
ever thought about calling in and put it
off we invite you to call in and talk
about our topic of the day
the c-span networks providing you access
to public affairs on television radio
and on the web
[Music]
afterwards with Pete Earley segregate
Redick off and Peter Ernest continues
welcome back Sergey Pete I wanted to ask
you
Sergey about what is one of the perhaps
one of the most controversial things
about the book and that is your naming
of a very prominent American strobe
Talbott a former senior editor for time
and the later of course the deputy
deputy director of the bedevi had the
State Department here in Washington and
you make it very clear in the book that
you did not that you are not saying that
strobe Talbot was a spy I think we
should make that very clear
absolutely but you do identify you use a
term of art an svr term of art as an
unofficial source an unofficial vessel
an official special contact a special
contact now as I read the relation the
the the your comments on strobe Talbot
he had discussions with Mammadov who was
his counterpart the deputy head of the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs and I would
expect in the course of such a
relationship that there would be
confidences shared insights I mean part
of people speaking at that level is not
to just give formal papers but to share
confidence insight how we go about
things but I think the fact that
Mammadov was a an svr coop t-that is he
was cooperating with intelligence
therefore the information from strobe
Talbot made its way through intelligence
channels rather than MFA Ministry of
Foreign Affairs channels therefore he
carries this this term an unofficial
special or trusted contact but but I
think it will probably be confusing for
Americans and you may want to comment on
this too one of the things you should
realize is it's not only is he talking
to someone who's a co-op T okay the SVR
is feeding that co-op T
questions to ask and that's important to
remember they're saying when you get
with this person when you get with this
hi State Department official try to turn
the conversation this way try to ask
this specific question try to get this
information and that is different than
someone who represents the State
Department
I mean strode Talbert would not I assume
would not have allowed the CIA to come
to him and say ask this question do this
do that I'm sure he felt independent
from them and that's not the way the
Russian was yeah
I understand the point you're making
what I would say though is no I don't
think strobe tell but would sort of take
a list of questions often so yeah but I
do think that he would take that he
would be prepared to meet with a CIA say
an analyst or briefer said you know mr.
Talbott mr. secretary
these are there a couple of issues were
very concerned about and we would really
appreciate learning any comments you
make on this I think he would take some
questions from CIA you're going beyond
my knowledge there because I don't know
how that functions but I do know
according to Sergei and he can address
this himself that the SVR looked at
strobe Talbott and thought here is
another American here is another
westerner who's rushing in to save
Russia and at that time the Soviet Union
collapse it needed help but I also think
that what Sergei said was the attitude
was we can massage his ego we can play
the helpless the naive we can say we
need your help please and by doing that
put him off guard and try to use him and
manipulate him because this is not the
first Westerner who's rushed in to save
you know Russia sure well Pete and I
have now both commented away you tell us
what you think you arranged first of all
I never called mr. Talbott a spy or I
think that he is an ardent American
patriot and he was never my
responsibility but because of my
position in the Senate I had access to
some documents to some files
we're strobe Talbott was called special
an official contact just mostly for
curiosity I asked some generals how come
now why you consider him such an
important source of information and
they'll then they explained to me that
my Madoff was used to ask tell the
specific questions of course this two
gentleman as far as I understand they
developed a good friendship but you know
it's my personal opinion when you're in
this high position when you have access
to top secrets
friendship with the foreign counterpart
for me it's true it's sounds little bit
strange you know French believe is a
good thing but not when you represent
your country in official position the
only one thing I was told that the good
thing for Russians was that mr Talbot
and mr. Madoff were had meetings data
that no third person present and again
it's all I can tell you but again what I
want to underline that mr Talbot wasn't
in any way Russian spy and you know one
thing that Talbot was opening himself up
for was that he doesn't know what the
Russian is going back and saying and
it's quite possible and Sergei was often
watching this with his own officers that
what was reported back may have been
highly exaggerated I mean we ran into
this with Dobrynin and Kissinger and
debates about that all the time where
the Russian official would go back and
perhaps say things trying to impress his
bosses oh I got him to tell me this
advancing his own agenda so it's just a
bad situation when you get on that one
in one it would it would be tricky and
that's that's one of your points and you
know people who are who worked and who
work in intelligence probably they
understand that sometimes we want a
look better than we are I know exactly
what you're saying and I think probably
in some way we're all guilty that that
is I think a diplomat an intelligence
officer a journalist progress you know
he wants his story his report to to look
as good as it can and that he succeeded
in learning this or he advanced our
country's goals by saying that so
there's there is that element I think in
almost all of us and I think when you
have a third party there that makes you
self sensor and that's I think your
point that's things you might say you
know privately run can run risky so
let's take this case I think and let's
take the case of strobe Talbott and I
understand that mahmoud off was a co-op
tea would you you wouldn't have any way
of knowing that perhaps strobe Talbott
was quite close to the intelligence
folks and was maybe maybe we wouldn't
say call him a co-op tea but you know
maybe he accepted intelligence it's very
possible that one thought that he's
milking his opponent okay they oppose
wealthy all I am doing great because I'm
looking him you know it's very very
possible and as you know in intelligence
it happens when it reaches the point of
this dramatic conversation when I am
recruiting you I am offering you
something something we both put
something on the table because you were
thinking that you are recruiting me I
was thinking that I was recruiting you
and we came to the same it happens it's
a paradox of Sergei tells a funny story
about how they were recruiting a German
and one of the points of this book that
he makes is that many countries
including NATO will not betray their own
secrets but they're happy to betray
American secrets that they feel like
America is a superpower it's an
imperialist so even though we're Ally's
allies we will and they get this German
and they're recruiting recruiting and he
turns out that he's an intelligence
officer from Germany who's trying to
recruit them well I think as we are both
until
officers we may have found ourselves in
similar positions silicon he was
valuable yeah it can prove valuable one
of the things that struck me was you
give such incredible insight into the
KGB into the KGB SVR and the practices
its approach to recruitment and I was
struck by the fact that you regarded the
UN as such a we have an expression in
American like shooting fish in a barrel
yes because you can't miss and and so in
the UN you made the statement here in
the book you said if one of my officers
could not recruit someone in the UN what
good was he yeah
could you expand on that actually UN is
a very good place to recruit people
first of all the whole world is is
presented but it has a lot of drawbacks
I don't want to offend diplomats of any
kind but sometimes they are not very
knowledgeable people and a lot of people
who work in UN they are more
concentrated on things we regret or we
deplore how to put it into this parallel
and they don't know real secret that's
why we were trying to recruit people who
had access to internal documentation
those who could provide us with some
intelligence not knowing real is the
subject but he can take something in his
mission and bring it to us and we were
capable to make our own analysis I want
to just stop briefly on basis of
recruitment the SVR uses Laura for them
it used to be ideological field II was
recruited this basis doesn't exist
anymore there is no anymore communism
this Bible base was replaced with
political base of recruitment to make it
look simple anti-american feelings
when you go to some European conferences
we'll go to some middle Middle East
Congress day a lot of people as you know
don't like America and they are ready to
cooperate with the SVR because they
don't like America second bases moral
psychological it's blackmailing we had a
kind of unwritten understanding between
Russians and Americans not to abuse this
base of recruitment because we have
hostages
both of us something you are
blackmailing me but there are American
diplomats in Moscow who could be
blackmail too but it basically exists
third bases the most the most the
easiest to understand financial my money
information and the force it was my
first I first introduced it by the way
it's business base of recruitment when
we create for our source I don't like
the word word spy spice is just as four
four four novels you know when we create
for a source business opportunities in
Russia legal personal works in the per
person works in Russia nothing wrong
with it he pasted taxes the business is
legal but with the understanding that
this business was created by the FSB and
again UN the in many recruitments there
was combination of different bases
elements from in UN the most effective
was political base of recruiting
anti-american he well in Canada he is
this it's interesting setting up a
business in Russia legitimized as you
know the hardest part is paying and
meeting with your person in your host
country so imagine if you had someone
who you recruited the United States and
you set up a business forum how easy it
is to fly there on this business get
legitimate pain
and we don't have any idea what a widget
is worth there so if they got inflated
prices you bring it back you know it's
it's so good it makes it much tougher to
catch someone and it sounds less even
less suspicious than banker consultant
where you can't sit where it's knowledge
whereas you're saying it's a business
this is something is widgets' or
something being sold and it's legitimate
yes I'm not hiding that I'm working I
have my enterprise in Russia I'm paying
taxes nothing wrong with it and you were
the first to think of this in the SVR
and were actually recognized for it was
it was the first joint venture between
SVR and FSK at that time then they
changed the name to FSB be like FBI and
CIA get internal and external
and it was this I spent several months
literally in the FSB dealing with mr.
gummy nuke and mr. Belenko they were two
senior officers working in the North
American Department of FSB we were just
planning the operation and the most
important thing it was to find good
people to perform the operation and it
was disaster disaster why because these
counter tells of sources they are
different from us then they use force
they work on the territory yeah they can
be [ __ ] and I needed someone more
finally we found a candidate which was
good but anyway they told me enough is
enough you must pick one you know I
would like to just touch on another
couple of things that the book is
extraordinarily interesting it but you
do touch on some of the very well-known
cases of recent years and one of them is
Colonel Yurchenko who of course defect
- this appeared to defect it's every
defendant read affected and and one of
the most frequent questions that I get
asked that the museum is was Colonel
Yurchenko a genuine defector or not and
you do touch on the case from urine of
it and I think your comments would be
fascinating actually
it was I think it was 85 85 yes I just
joined the American Department I was a
young starting officer and I thought
that I won't survive more than 6 months
in this department because the people
were so bright you know and I thought
that I'll never be someone like them and
then I had a first assignment to write
an article for for internal magazine
called rosy cheeked intelligence officer
about hero name would name your chenko
he just returned back from he escaped
and then returned back to the service
and I asked can I interview him they
don't know you cannot but you must write
the body article about Russia hero how
come you're an intelligence officer
figure it out you know I wrote this
article of course no no concrete facts
because I had no idea what he did I just
knew that what was his position he was
deputy head of the American Department
deputy to famous Russian intelligence
general
yakusan probably somehow heard the name
and I wrote this this article and then
the one senior guy he told me thank you
mister tragical that you wrote this
article then we'll send this article to
the personnel department and we'll
attach you this article to your personal
dos here it's it's the end of your
career why I know why because you are an
idiot
you took is it the fact
he is not here it means that they were
still thinking how to present the case
and I'm sure and the paradox is that you
think Oh was decorated they assigned him
to kneel to a Research Institute where
he had no access to any secret but
officially he was given the the very
high internal decoration he became the
Honorable cheekiest and I know that you
know yes another world member of the
organization and they did it in order to
to hide what happened in reality of
course he defected I don't know what
happened to him then probably he wasn't
treated properly I don't know but when I
finally met him briefly he produced only
a very strange impression probably he
wasn't totally sane I know one thing
that he was finding every other week
terminal illnesses with himself all
kinds you know he was really medical
encyclopedia oh I have this I'll die and
this is the this is what I know about
the case well then I met him many many
times just in the corridors you know you
had a comment well this is what's so
fascinating about espionage as you know
it's that wilderness of mirrors and
believing as this person a defector is
he nodded when I did the Walker book I
had people say to me Oh John Walker
didn't really betray his country in a
few years they're gonna release him to
Russia and he's going to be a double
agent and you know I mean you can come
up with any kind of nonsense and the
question is how do you verify it and
with this case you know I talked to
Americans I talked to Ames about you
Gingka I talked to Russians about him
and I don't know of anyone who dealt
with him personally who believed he
wasn't a genuine defector but you'll
still have people who will see you know
and you know Angleton's famous for
saying all these things and people
defending it back and forth well we read
a lot of novels
a lot of movies but but my question back
to you though is so you were regarded as
an idiot for writing your article
however here is your check Oh who's
clearly they understand that he did
defect he was not a hero
and yet he was decorated and and and
everybody you know he was not he was not
he did not get the the treatment that
puka chef and Motorin and Yakov didn't
answer this question I heard Khrushchev
he put it this way I tried to find
polite words you Gingka was in a deep
bed substance but he managed to get out
of his best substance by himself he came
back right yes he wasn't deep something
but he managed to condemn any defection
is not something the intelligence
service is proud of it's a failure it's
a major major major failing then in
Russia then and now you know sometimes
our I envy American bureaucrats
whatever happens nothing happens to have
to them you did a hell of a job you know
in rationale if there is a failure it
means some people must be sacrificed
somebody must be punished absolutely
that's why when you reach some high
position you always think when you sign
a document because if something goes
wrong who authorized this particular
operation oh well in the case of your
checker you spell out very clearly in
your book that a general a coachman was
forced to resign not become huge anchor
and the others Mathurin and okay and the
others the others and the the thought
that America
Department of the SVR and the American
branch not only not only geographical
political intelligence but Science and
Technology became the nest of spies and
they they needed scapegoat someone must
must be sacrificed but again where the
huge anchor it wasn't that simple first
of all you Bianca was not supposed to go
abroad at all because he worked in the
Department of Internal Security period
these people they have they cannot leave
the country till they die you know they
they they are not authorized it was an
exception who approved this exception
could scoff himself it means to make a
loud case from you it means Khrushchev
would expose himself yes that's why in
many cases there are no much waves
because too many high-ranking people
were involved in the case and if they
start making waves they expose it
themselves there was also the the sense
and of course you you know the Ames case
very well there was also a sense in
American intelligence that that a
Yurchenko was was not punished in order
to conceal Ames who was a new reporting
source to the SVR they did not want to
reveal what they knew what Ames might
have reported and therefore your Chico
was recognized as a hero it's possible
but you know they executed so many
people yes after and I always ask myself
a question how unprofessional was it to
start killing people immediately the
death row for intelligence officer was
like for six months maximum it's not
like in the United States people die of
natural causes in jail yes and it was a
kind of in my opinion very
unprofessional because they exposed by
the fact that the sources that they at
least the new that appear that there
were sources somewhere in the American
intelligence community I think just as a
final note before we close are you are
you at all optimistic about what is
going on in Russia now no what is your
comment I mean and this is because you
use the word when we first began talking
that you escaped and do you still have
that sense that about the situation in
Russia it's something to escape from
it's not even the matter of who is in
charge Putin or mediated who will
replace Putin and Putin will replace
Medvedev I think it's a pathetic very
stupid game you know everyone
understands what's going on in the rel
to that Putin wants to stay in power in
any way the whole system how they run
the country is is evil it's based on the
wrong principles they don't think about
the well-being of Russian Russian people
they always repeat that they have
tremendous social programs whatever go
to Russia I have Russian satellite dish
I'm watching the Russian TV Moscow st.
Petersburg probably some more few places
the rest is 17th century people don't
have running water in one estimates I
heard that there are productive
population in Russia not more than 17
million other either too old or chronic
drugs who improved the situation where
is the improvement and at the same time
and it's for me it's disgusting how
there's not the best people spending
thousands millions in a very tasteful
way you know
I always compare like mr. boffin I don't
know American billionaires we all help
the society they donate their money they
leave very modest lives by the way I
think the fittest yes driving us in old
Volvo and something like that
aerated somewhere yes because he is a
good he is a good citizen those who are
running the country you know it's not an
exaggeration when I had to shake hands
with these people I was rushing all the
time to the men's room to clean my hands
well sir